[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette habitude qu'a pris ce mouvement
qui se dit être un mouvement de
rassemblement que d'exclure que de
couper des têtes de tous ceux qui n'ont
pas mis un genou devant marine le pen
qui n'adoptent pas cette marino latry en
toutes circonstances eric zemmour est un
très bon intellectuelle un polémiste
mais je ne crois pas qu'il puisse après
emmanuel macron rassembler les français
à briser leurs exemple l'ancien numéro 2
des verts guillaume pelletier stéphane
ravier ce matin sénateurs n de marseille
qui le rejoignent à partir de là il est
évidemment cohérent logique
de soutenir eric zemmour je vais donc
soutenir maintenant tout de suite eric
zemmour dans cette campagne
présidentielle c'est la troisième
défection de taille en moins d'un mois
dans le camp de la candidate du
rassemblement national depuis des mois
stéphane ravier se met les petits
cailloux tel le petit poucet pour nous
amener au chemin qu'il a pris
aujourd'hui on le savait depuis
longtemps il n'a pas eu le courage de le
faire plus tôt cette élection
présidentielle ressemble de plus en plus
à la fédération française de football
quoi sert qu'on achète des joueurs c'est
un maire c'est un grand mercato depuis
septembre le genre des républicains
partent rejoindre emmanuel macron je
considère qu emmanuel macron mais pas le
diable et le candidat ait l'air n'est
pas dieu que ya pas de traîtrise
évidemment là dedans les idées surplombe
tout l'intérêt du pays surplomb tous ses
fans ravir retrouve probablement chez
eric zemmour le front national 10 à 20
ou 30 ans
dans une forme de parti de témoignages
et de et de contestation ce sont des
amoureux de la provocation
nous avons eu une conversation entre
amis une conversation franche et
affectueuse parce qu'il va vous soutenir
côté je suis très heureuse de cet
entretien je ne vous en dirai pas plus
les taxes excessives et des amours
balles et les
crédits
[Musique]
cette vigneronne quatre pick six heures
[Applaudissements]
elle est au milieu d'eux dans un milieu
un confortable parce qu'ils des eaux
logiquement l air n'a pas réussi pendant
ces cinq dernières années imposer un
corpus qui s'impose au fond emmanuel
macron et qui empêche eric zemmour de
naître
vole quelque peu chahuté entre paris et
cayenne vendredi trois passagers se sont
battus à tel point que des membres
d'équipage d'air caraïbes et d'autres
voyageurs ont dû intervenir pour les
séparer des vidéos ont circulé comme
celle ci sur les réseaux sociaux dans
dix ans serons nous encore la septième
puissance du monde serons nous encore
une nation souveraine ou un auxiliaire
des états unis un comptoir de la chine
serons-nous une nation unie ou une
nation éclaté
face à ces questions vitales pas de
fatalité ni aux grandes et classement ni
au grand remplacement appelle jean mus
sortant de la pandémie que voici ces
convois de la liberté sur les quêtes de
nouveaux recommence la propagande le
harcèlement et d'injures le mépris
après paris direction bruxelles
beaucoup sont rentrés chez eux mais ils
sont encore plusieurs centaines de
véhicules dans le convoi dit de la
liberté
[Musique]